the jurogan experience but i'm also very
childlike in that way because i think a
lot of that kind of got
you know taken away a little bit so i
still you know i still enjoy cartoons
and marvel movies or whatever it is and
these type of things these escapism
stuff that i feel like i just never
really kind of fully got out of the way
and so it's like you grew up fast and
now it's like you're making up for lost
time and doing that kind of stuff i
started embracing them again i thought
they were foolish like comic books and
comic book movies and stuff like that i
thought they were foolish for a while
and then i got as i got older i go but
wait a minute i like those and then i
started embracing them as i got in i
guess into my 30s
yeah i think i think you should have a
better understanding and again not to
get so super deep on
superhero movies but i think there is
something that that really kind of
shines a mirror on people to if you have
this blank canvas and be able to create
something
as to
whatever you wanted and then you can
create this person it's kind of
interesting i remember i forgot there's
an essay going around or something
that's talking about like superman for
instance like how
there is some interesting psychology
behind it the idea that everyone on
krypton is superman and his alter ego is
actually a human as opposed to every
other
superhero his alter ego is their
superhero but he actually has to pretend
to be normal because he just himself is
you know whatever it's like this weird
kind of thing and i remember reading
that kind of stuff and thinking about
that and thinking about how like
um most recently i think spider-man they
finally cast a young young guy as
opposed to like a grown man and there's
like what kind of stuff would you go
through as a teenager that all of a
sudden
discovered that you have all this stuff
going on and they did a good job in the
most recent movies about him going to
high school and telling his best friend
and getting caught about it and getting
all this stuff i feel like there's like
as an adult watching it is not the same
i think i really enjoy it on a different
level
but it's cool yeah well it's just
superhero movies
they're just fun that's all it is that's
right it's just it's fun it's junk food
yeah yeah enjoy it right for the mind
yeah i think that there's there's a time
like when people would come by and say
this didn't have any it's like are you
arguing the realism like the people who
pick it apart like that it's just kind
of they can do whatever they want like
if that's what you want to do with a
superhero movie yeah go back and do that
about bugs bunny too stupid that's right
exactly exactly oh he got shot in the
face you could totally not survive that
like yeah exactly he's talking rabbit
bro yeah exactly none of it makes any
sense you know what i watched the other
day that i haven't seen in a long time
the watchman yes that's a [ __ ] up
movie yeah but that's uh there's um
i mean that is so well written yeah and
especially the new have you have you
watched the series the tv
i was watching the series for a little
bit dr manhattan's [ __ ] like dr
manhattan's supposed to be a glowing
nuclear blue guy with a giant dick and
also he's a regular guy right
what is this nonsense right that's like
if the hulk was just a guy who like went
to crossfit wait wait wait in the in the
hbo series yes yeah i mean i mean so bro
he's supposed to be super jacked with a
giant dick that's true okay that's the
that's that's
what dr manhattan is right he's supposed
to be able to like time travel and do
whatever he wants yeah go to other
planets and [ __ ] yeah he seems way too
normal yeah
let's see let me see what he looks like
pull up what he looks like because the
one in the in the watchman the movie
like it looks like what you'd expect a
god to look like he's got the crazy
white eyes he's almost like animated
whereas everybody else in this show is
you know basically
just a person with superpowers for sure
and some of them don't even have
supervisors and i think that that's
that's again that's one of those things
where living in a world oh god what is
that yeah look at him get the [ __ ] out
of here how is that dr manhattan
that's ridiculous
the real dr manhattan in the movies like
a perfect specimen he's like a god he
glows
and then this other one is just like a
dude with makeup on like they just got
lazy like i don't understand it
there's a
what is the
oh my god i can't i'm blanking on it
look at him look at that that's not it
that's not it that's not it
that's that's a cosplay yeah it's just
some guys for uh hanging out halloween
or something yeah is that what it is
thank god
i threw up in my mouth let him let
himself go it just
i just watched it for a little bit and i
was like i don't know it's just
but it is it is more raw i think that
the the when you're talking about a show
or move or that kind of stuff when you
start to kind of blend these superhero
um situations into real life like people
aren't gonna be cool with everything and
they're not all gonna be cool
you know like that's the thing i think
there's been a couple you dystopian type
of things where
what if superman was bad he decided to
do terrible [ __ ] it's like we what could
we do well that's the thing about the
watchman right like the comedian is a
terrible person and the watchman yeah
the guy with the mustache and the cigar
i mean he's [ __ ] horrible horrible
he's a murderer yeah you know and but
yet he's a superhero that's very
yeah very conflicted yeah the power yeah
absolute power corrupts absolutely that
type of thought process right there's
what is the um
what's that move that the series the
god to come out same similar situation
where um it's a superhero story and it's
about
uh the same thing about these
superheroes like doctor
no sorry mister something god man i'm
blanking on it but but they basically go
follow these superheroes that just
aren't good people i know what you're
talking about
yeah
the boys the boys i didn't watch that
was that good it's good i thought it was
like a watchman a watchman rip off you
can kind of see it that way but it's
obviously it's just very well written
yeah you can see it that way but it's
like when you make evil superheroes like
that's a but it's it's it's really it is
true i mean if you had
if you gave somebody a ridiculous amount
of power or whatever it is yeah how
could you possibly
expect that person to just decide to
choose
pure
right you know that's what we have what
right now with the government yeah give
a lot of power they just listen
yeah exactly it's a it's a weird time
for that
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify